on the bond tonight for your friars is
joe musgrove 28 year old local kid
making his 29 start his fourth start
against the giants this season remember
last time out he got a lot of love seven
runs of support 15 quality starts with
the most by a padres since 2017. points
hitting 204 off of joe musgrove
in the first game of the last series
between these two teams last monday
night at oracle park in san francisco le
stella hit a lead-off home run against
udarvish he throws there's a swing
there's a drive deep in the right field
way back there it could go it's gone
and listen to these giants fans at petco
park tommy lestella leads off the game
with a home run
sixth home run of the year
for la stella one-nothing giants
stella hit that one into straight away
right field and it was not a sure thing
that it was gonna go it just barely made
it over the wall by three or four feet
and listen to the ovation for buster
posey as he is introduced cozy hitting
297 18 homers 18 doubles 47 driven in
and that's strike three posey newt takes
with him the first strikeout for
muskrobe so good job by muskrobe to
battle back there in a big way that
looks like a little cut fastball that
just kind of backs up a little bit
buster posey frozen pizza one out and
one on a run in and lamont wade junior
swing that bone is punched in the left
center field it gets down base head
tommy fan the left fielder over to pick
it up toward left center a base is
loaded one out situation with the giants
already getting a run here in the inning
pitch on the way crawford ground ball to
second base frazier's got it to second
one tatis's turn in time double play and
the inning is over musgrove was tested
but he battles out of it and gets the
inning ending double play off the bat of
brandon crawford and the giants get just
one here in the top of the first inning
on the bound for the san francisco
giants is kevin gausman 30 year old
making his 31st start and if you
remember he faced the pod race for the
second straight start
following that thursday afternoon
starting san francisco he throws the
fourth seam of the split to change up
and the slider boy big number since the
all-star break pre-all-star break 173
era post
477 see if the potteries can get to him
early tonight tati's 285 average 39
homers 92 driven in here comes splatters
struck him out swinging
that ball comes back a little bit
and then just drops off the table manny
machado now the powerful right-handed
hitter two down nobody on they're set
and ready the 2-1 pitch and manny hits
it a mile in the air to deep left field
forget it towards the western metal
gonna go
off the balcony on the top level and the
padres have tied it up on manny
machado's 25th home run of the season
oh he said before the game he wanted to
get the focus back to the field trying
to win some ball games no better way to
do that than to go up in the western
metal supply company building there are
on occasion times when he will hang it
and you know what happens you hangy oh
and manny will bang him and it's a two
ball no strike count to fan he throws
fastball grounded right to short
crawford has it flips the ball to la
stella at second for the force out on
frazier and the inning is over each team
gets a run see if joe musgrove can get
aboard here with two outs and turn that
up over four four 47 at the plate this
year is joe muscaro showing bun drops it
down the third baseline's a good one
guzman's got no play
what a bunt base hit for joe musgrove
first in second two down for fernando
opposite field base hit for fernando
here comes grisham he'll score
musgrove stops it third throw to second
he is safe stayed on the bag and the
padres take it to one lead
there is some serious energy working
through this lineup right now
almost the thought of that split finger
actually helps fernando on this head
back he sees the fastball a little bit
longer
than he normally would just to play it
safe annie machado leads off here in the
third padres by a run he homered his
first time up
high drive deeply filled man oh man oh
mayonnaise got deep twice
homer in the first he homers in the
third and the padres take a 3-1 lead he
continues to put his bat where his mouth
is another hanging slider to manny and
he loses it he is not messing around
bring up tommy fab
high drive left field for fam and it's
fantastic
out to left field tommy pham his 15th of
the year and the padres have a 4-1 lead
against the giants
nothing like some home cooking first
manny now tommy pham this one on a line
out to left field stay hot tommy can you
hear me
joel musgrove loves it getting some love
getting four runs three run lead he's
got a base knock already the steaming on
that bunt
and he's got another
one ripped by longoria third base in the
left field corner it's an extra base hit
musgrove sails into second with a double
so now wilmer flores is the pinch hitter
for kevin gausman and wilmer is the
possible tying run and a slider is
grounded into left field a base hit
longoria
comes in to score boomer flores got that
cutter or a slider and he just hooked it
right between third and short and the
one-o pitch
swing and buster hits a high drive in
the center over to his right goes
grisham he's under it he's got it
tagging at third is just
and he'll come in to score
the other runners
remain right where they were
a sacrifice fly for posey and now it's
four to three san diego one and two to
wade swing and a miss musgrove struck
him out with an elevated fastball at six
for joe and he does limit the damage
here in the fifth and here's joshua
crawford has rolled out twice
crawford pokes one the other way and
this game is tied he will end up at
second base with four to four folks
brandon crawford with the clutch hit the
pitch on the way
the curveball is swung on and driven to
center field medium deep right center
under it is pro far now he comes in as
he makes the catch crawford is coming
here comes the throw it is much too late
crawford scores standing up and the
giants have gone ahead now 5-4 giants
high drive deep left field
back goes brian at the wall
ball's gone
home run for austin nola the padres tie
it up five to five bryant went up
against the fence left nearly made an
unbelievable catch
runner on first two outs tied at five in
the eighth inning fly ball deep right
center field
back is meyers at the wall and will
makes the catch he brings it back in the
yard myers with a great catch at the
fence in right center will myers says no
doubt at second cozy at first and here
is lamont ray jr and the pitch
fastball swung on and a looping laner
over the head of tati's into shallow
left base hit heading home is belt here
comes the throw the tag
safe
that one hit the glove and rolled away
as nola tried to make the tag wow some
daring base running there here's the
pitch
right at the knees straight three call
the sinker got him looking now manny
machado the one strike pitch swinging a
hard ground ball off of belch club he
picks it back up throws to crawford for
one back to first with rogers covering
in time double play the game is over